if the nfl had a seven game a good one
super bowl losers that would have won it
all if they'd had a chance to win four
out of the next six you know how the
best of seven goes so go ahead the coin
toss will not be best of seven tails
tails tails tails tails tail sales tail
he's trying to end the streak of three
straight losses will it be a head will
it be a tails he ends the streak all
right baby go ahead i don't i don't mind
today because there is no obvious one
there are plenty of great great choices
go ahead no i think there no you're
right there is no obvious one uh i don't
think but i i think there's maybe one
that jumps out to the rest of you know
or jumps out than the rest and i'm gonna
go with the oh the the 07 new england
patriots i am that's going to be my
first choice and this is not an easy an
easy draft but yeah they lost a
heartbreaker and super bowl 42 to the
new york giants you know
i i get that 17-13 it was a great
football game to watch now
do i think that the new york giants
probably played the best game they were
absolutely capable of playing yes i do
and do i think new england didn't play
their best game of the year at that
point yes i do as well now again i'm not
trying to take any credit from the new
york giants but i just still think this
is a new england team that if you just
go
through the positions the team the
coaches hey it's close i understand the
giants had a lot of good things there
that what i'm mentioning as well but i
just think that the greatness of the new
england patriots over a series would
have won out and they would have won
like a a series four to three uh or
maybe four two when all said and done
yeah and look here's the thing about the
patriots the more you play them the more
they are going to learn what you do and
they're going to make it harder and
harder for you to win and there would
have to be a huge gap in talent the
other way for the patriots to not
eventually overcome it and in this case
the the the talent difference you know
the patriots were better than the giants
yeah right
on that one day it worked for the giants
i think over the course of a seven game
series with bill belichick figuring out
how to attack the giants and how to make
changes one game after another that
would eventually result in the patriots
winning enough games right i'm gonna go
way way back here because this was the
first great upset of the super bowl era
this was the team that was supposedly
unbeatable and the new york jets found a
way to make it happen the baltimore
colts 1968 if you go seven games then
the baltimore colts i guarantee would
have won at least four of the next six
because it was kind of fluky the jets
caught the colts flat-footed the colts
came in with you know a lot of of uh of
of optimism and almost a presumption
they were going to win it wasn't a
question of whether they'd win it was
how many points they'd win by and once
they got hit in the mouth early they
never quite recovered there was that
moment late in the first half of the
game when earl morrill had jimmy or wide
open right play they had used before and
why didn't he throw the ball why didn't
he see jimmy or so if you give the colts
a chance to recover from losing game one
they're gonna they're gonna end up
winning that series and they may win it
four to one yeah no i mean that you know
again it's not like i was alive to watch
these teams but i love nfl history nfl i
was three i don't remember much about
the game but anything you hear is that
yeah going into the matchup the colts
were clearly the dominant team everybody
expected them to win the server that's
what's great about football it comes
down to one moment one game and you know
human emotions and one team's being told
damn we're good and we're going to win
the super bowl the other team's being
told you don't have a chance you're
going to lose this thing and you know
yeah these are both professionals so one
team might be greater but not so great
that you know those human emotions might
not tip the scales a little bit and
that's where it came down to and yeah it
seems like the colts you know
quarterback play wasn't that good that
day and and joe joey uh joe willie
namath was on fire so uh that's what led
to that so not a bad pick by you that
was on my list as well um
my next one i'm going vice versa here on
the patriots i'm going with the 01 uh st
louis rams you know again you know we
you talked about how new england the
more they get to play you know the more
they'll get to know your tendencies well
i actually think in this be in this case
it would have benefited the rams to play
new england more because to what you
said a minute ago i think the rams were
significantly more talented team on the
field there was a pretty good gap as far
as talent the rams it wasn't just the
greatest show on turf this is one thing
people forget about the rams you know
when they won the super bowl they were
the number one defense in football this
year in the 2001 season it was the
number three defense in football so they
were a really well-rounded football team
and i think the great game planning in a
one-game scenario caught the rams off
guard because they played bill belichick
who had two weeks and they were like
what the heck nobody's played us this
way what are they doing and i just look
at that and go yeah if they got another
look or got a feel for what new england
did that was so you know different in
their attack that i think that
ultimately their talent would have
overcome and if it became a seven game
series and they would have won that like
four three four two something like that
too
and actually chris to make what
belichick did even more impressive they
only had a one-week turnaround that's
right because that was that was uh 9 11
that year that's right yeah and and they
still they still came up with a great
game plan but i this that's what i was
referring to earlier that talent gap
would have been so much that mike march
the coach of the rams at the time
eventually would have put the ego down
because he
he refused to take what the patriots
were giving it right at some point he
just said screw it if they're going to
give it to us and we're going to run
marshall falk 50 times a game and we're
going to run him right down their
throats and we're going to win the game
now i'm going to i thought here's where
you were going when you said we were
flipping around i thought you were
flipping around from the perspective of
the giants because it was the giants and
and bill belichick who knocked off the
bills in 1990 in super bowl 25 and it's
his same idea there was a huge talent
gap between the bills and the giants
bill belichick put together the master
game plan that slowed down the k-gun
offense he was not going to slow down
the k-gun offense over a seven-game
series and they just barely beat the
bills as it was i think it's like the
fifth time we've mentioned super bowl
barely
25
this
bills as it was right and and uh
you play that game
up to six more times and the bills are
going to win at least four of those
games because scott norwood is going to
get a shot at redemption at some point
and that 47-yard field goal is not going
to go wide right and here's the reality
right you're not going to need a
last-second field goal from scott
norwood if you get a chance to put that
bills team on the field with the giants
again no no no no question mike i'm with
you i you know listen i think my dad and
some of his teammates would probably
tell you the same thing you know i've
heard my dad say you know they lost the
bills in the regular season that year as
the you know the game my dad broke his
foot in and wasn't able to to finish the
season or go into the playoffs with but
you know
i i've heard him say it i've heard other
teammates of him say yeah that buffalo
bills team was better than us but you
know the the giants were machines as far
as knowing how to win bill parcells bill
belichick situational football and they
executed it was you know parcels
belichick that's what they did yeah
we're not as good but we're gonna
execute what we do
to a level that you have never seen
before and that was the greatness of
that giant's offense and defense right
the run game and the defense that they
played that day you're right i'm with
you that would have been my next i
tossed around the 0-1 rams and the 90
bills i wasn't sure which one to go with
there so uh good pick by you i'm not
going to fight that at all now it gets
interesting so it gets interesting it
does and i'm gonna go here
with the 09 indianapolis colts okay
that's uh and this is tough when you get
down to this category here but you know
i understand these teams were pretty
close but i do think that the
indianapolis colts were the better
football team over that new orleans
saints football team one thing that i
always remember you know i always
thought gosh if dwight freeny didn't
have the bad high ankle sprain in that
super bowl i think that would have been
a whole different game uh don't forget
the onside kick okay at the start of the
second half that was a huge
game-changing moment you know pierre
gossan at one point dropped a wide open
pass down the middle where i don't know
if anybody touches him i think he's
going to score a touchdown or at least
get very close on a third down when the
colts were really controlling the game
early on and i don't think you can
depend on peyton manning throwing late
game interception and throughout a seven
game series two so that would be my next
one i think the 09 colts would beat
those 09 saints in a seven game series
i got one for you that uh i you know
what i i've i've got a bunch of
different ones i can do
but
i remember vividly
after the packers had won super bowl 31
over the new england patriots and they
were great the following year and they
they made it back to the softball and
and it was the pa of course the packers
are going to beat the broncos and john
elway can't win a super bowl he's been
horrible in the super bowl and the
packers are great and the packers have
reggie white and they've got brett favre
and this is going to be easy next thing
you know the broncos end up winning that
game i think on a seven game series the
packers end up being the better team the
packers end up winning enough games the
broncos really caught them that day yeah
and i don't think it would especially
with a guy like mike holmgren coaching
the packers i don't think the the
broncos would have been able to figure
them out enough times to win the series
i i i
i'm not they were on my short list here
as well mike i thought about that too
you know that was a really awesome
packers football team i mean they were
really good and yeah i think ultimately
what won that game for the denver
broncos was
really creative game planning by mike
shanahan i've heard guys like leroy
butler on nfl films and things talk
about you know yeah they did things with
their offense and especially the run
game that day that put the packers in a
bind to where yeah i think if a series
goes out they start to figure those type
of things out and then terrell davis is
not gashing them for 10 yards every time
he touches the ball in between the
tackles so i'm not mad at you there
either this is a good draft i had a lot
of fun with this one because it wasn't
settle off some other you got some other
ones
that are on your list rattle them off i
think the 15 carolina panthers i think
if they played that denver bronco team
seven times they're gonna win let's not
forget it was a sack fumble for a
touchdown it was cam newton's strip sack
fumble close to his own goal line for
the other touchdown so i think the
carolina panthers were the better team
the other one i thought about
i didn't have the gut but the 14 the 14
seahawks i thought that 14 seahawks team
was better than the new england patriots
but again new england showed their
greatness in those one-game situations
but those were other ones that were on
my list
hey 2011 patriots against the giants
yeah
2017 patriots against the eagles in a
seven game series i think they end up
winning that how about the rams from
just this past year seven games against
the patriots yeah right they're not
going to score three points in seven
games i guarantee you that right so uh
and and one last one because it was a
controversial game uh because the
officiating but the steelers when they
beat the seahawks seahawks the better
team in super bowl 40. good one there i
had totally forgot about that you're
right that was a day man i still feel
bad for matt hassell back there i mean
matt hasselbeck first of all is one of
the more underrated great quarterbacks
of our era and gosh did he play good
that day and the team and the referees
let the seattle seahawks down
all right quick break let's see the
recap i've got the 68 colts the 1990
bills the 97 packers and chris has the
07 patriots 01 rams and the 2009
indianapolis colts
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports